تجعل ملامحكم تبدو وكانها اصغر سنا لا
تعتمد على اساليب مساحيق التجميل العاديه
بل هي تقنيه معتمده على ذكاء اصطناعي ابهر
العالم
الممثله المصريه لبنى ونس ادهشت جميع من
تابع مسلسل جعفر العمده ظهرت بعمر الشباب
دون اي اثار للشيخوخه البعض اعتقد ان
المخرج استعان بممثله شابه تشبه ملامحها
لكن الحقيقه انها ادت المشاهد بنفسها
بالاستعانه بتقنيه تسمى
تم استخدام تقنيه دي ايجينغ في العديد من
افلام هوليود سابقا التقنيه صغرت ملامح
وجهي الممثلين الكبيرين الباتشينو وروبرت
دينيرو في فيلم ذا ايريشمان دينيرو اظهر
بعض الرضا عن هذه التاثيرات المرئيه
الجديده لمقاومه الشيخوخه لكنه في الوقت
نفسه حذر من ان الافراط في استخدام هذه
التقنيات قد يحول السينما العريقه الى
مجرد مشاهد كرتونيه
فعلا
لم يقتصر استخدام هذه التقنيه على وجه
الممثل فقط بل الاغرب انها استخدمت على
كامل الاجسام لاول مره بتاريخ صناعه
السينما
فتقنيه دينك تعتمد على استخدام المؤثرات
البصريه لتحويل ملامح الممثلين لسن اصغر
بدل الاعتماد على المكياج التقليدي خاصه
في مشاهد الفلاش باك هذه التقنيه تصغر
العمر عن طريق تحرير الصوره رقميا او
باستخدام تركيب الصور التي تم انشاؤها
بواسطه الكمبيوتر عاده يتم استخدام منصه
معقده مكونه من ثلاث كاميرات منها
كاميرتان تعملان بالاشعه تحت الحمراء مع
حلقات اضاءه بالاشعه تحت الحمراء على
الجانبين
في فيلم جيميني مان للممثل ويل سميث تم
استخدامه هذه التقنيه ايضا
رغم كل ذلك هناك تهديد يخص المواهب الشابه
لانه في السابق كانت هناك فرصه للممثلين
المبتدئين لان يقوموا بدور الشباب لممثل
كبير في السن وهو ما اتاح الفرصه لهؤلاء
الصغار ان ياخذوا فرصتهم ويصبحوا فيما بعد
نجوما كبار لكن تقنيه
يمكنها ان تتسبب مستقبلا في ندره للمواهب
الشابه فالتقدم التكنولوجي وصل حدا مخيفا
في صناعه وفبركه المشاهد السينمائيه اخرها
ما شاهدناه من فيديوهات لباراك اوباما
مزيفه وتبدو نسخه طبق الاصل عنه كما
تابعنا محاكاه بصريه لترامب في شبابه فهل
تهدد هذه التقنيات مستقبل المواهب او حتى
كبار الممثلين او ربما تقلص من ادوارهم
بنسبه كبيره